greetings my friends and welcome to a
dummy Christmas review let us talk about
all the ranking best stop-motion
Christmas stories there's this world
where everybody seems to have cold dead
puppet eyes most of the males have
lipstick on their mouths and half the
people seem to have lines around their
jaws to talk about the stories that
comes out of this world is kind of
redundant because well a lot of them
have the same story
somebody doesn't fit in they try to
journey someplace where they feel they
belong they sing they come across a mean
obstacle that in the end it's probably
gonna be a nice obstacle and they go
right back to where they started because
the original place where they came from
decided to stop being dicks aside from
that what can I say about the
rankin/bass stop-motion stories first
areas he'll think don't look alive or it
looks like that used to be a life and
then somebody took him and tournament
two dead people and they're like that
because Jay Leno chin things looks like
it's gonna eat me Santa Claus has
raisins for Beautiful's the Snowman has
no feet so how does he move is it like a
snake it slithers the Snowman as that
snake pits Evo and they all seem to move
really fast and then standstill at
really awkward moment why do people
watch this every Christmas it's charity
Freddy Krueger's for cuddling than any
of those things I don't know why you
watch it what you do on the plus side I
guess your nightmares are a lot more
creative because of it so I can't argue
with the fact that you enjoyed these
films and you watch them every single
Christmas season but excuse me if I turn
off the TV set and hide under my
blankets frosty slithers this is
chittery food see don't go away
Christmas I want to stay in this robe
you